build-it draw flame
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is bdp building Tom Miller built a
personal train track that runs around
his nearly 20 acre property he has
handmade steam locomotives 11,000 feet
of track 30 foot tall railroad trestle
and a 400 foot long tunnel
Randall Rosenthal creates amazing wooden
sculptures that look like paper objects
all of his projects start from a single
block of wood and our hand-painted ones
carved some of his works include a
cardboard box full of cash
newspapers box full of baseball cards
and binders full of paper mr. Finch is a
self-taught artist that sews nature
inspired original creations they look
similar to taxidermy and uses recycled
materials to make them including tea
making spider Halloween hairs and faux
lenka a larger sculpture made from
leather and fake fur Brett Kern creates
these hyper-realistic ceramic sculptures
that look like inflatable toys they
range from inflatable dinosaurs to
balloons and a spaceman he sells them on
his Etsy page and it takes at least a
month to hand make them to order draw
empty gestures is a body art project by
Heather Hansen each life-size drawing is
created by holding charcoal in each hand
and making choreographed movements
across the paper
she says she's looking for ways to
download her movement directly onto
paper emptying gestures from one form to
another michael Mapes creates these
intricate collage portraits out of
scientific specimens he uses parts of
photographic prints glass vials insect
pins dried botanical matter and other
materials to create his works inspired
by Dutch painters and now for some
pieces from the art of tokine series by
chin wall
breakthrough films is creating the
world's first feature-length painted
animation about the life of Vincent van
Gogh it's told entirely through his
paintings and the characters in them
fifty six thousand eight hundred
paintings will be made by the film's 40
painters in order to create the finished
piece plyatt composer Johnny random
created be spoken music made only using
sounds from his bike
Jackson parody does cover songs with his
accordion
here's his version of those who fight
from Final Fantasy 7
you
direct from Norway here's ice used as an
instrument at the ice concert in yellow
finally here's the official video for
can't see you bye Len Kem's featuring
Slick Don with animation by prefix
studio submit your video as a personal
message here on YouTube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to only your creations and as
always thanks for watching
you